thank you
[Music]
so there's a this is a really cool story
about a bunch of McDonald's employees
who all have something very interesting
in common and I think in a world where
we're trying to find more diversity
inclusion this is a maybe a good example
what do you guys think it is
diversity include Burger King
they like Burger King yeah they could
say like Burger King
huh you're right and you want a thousand
dollars
what thanks what okay let me catch you
up real quick so so sorry for everybody
we have to catch Joel so rehash there's
a bunch of McDonald's employees who all
have the same one thing in common what
do you think it is Joe
one thing in common all McDonald's
everybody works at McDonald's
the specific McDonald's right oh one
McDonald's one McDonald's franchise but
they all have one thing in common
they live there
they don't live there not a sick ass
sitcom I mean in the same neighborhood
it was oh this made me sad they have the
same trying to imagine it they have the
same mother
they do not have the same mother that's
a good guess they're all stealing
they're now is it about their
physicality you said diversity and
inclusion right well just it's just like
you know a bunch of people working
together but like oh they did it 23andMe
they all found out that their their dad
is the same sperm donor
oh they all just shut the [__] just in
the Fry Basket so close they're all
[__] each other oh they're all
[__] each other and they all have
gonorrhea because of it oh cool yeah
that's pretty common though wow
at the workplace if you ever go to a
Trader Joe's and you look around you're
just looking on they're all [__] each
other yeah but they're all getting
Gunners are they really
or is it like one person [__] this
person this person [__] this person
it's like an improv shirt oh is that
like [__] everybody Yeah because
sometimes they have different shifts
different night shifts yeah different
Dynamics and then sometimes people
[__] the coach and the coach is
[__] one of the students oh yeah that
that usually happens it happens all the
time that's true because it it's hard to
meet people after college and this is
before dating apps so it was pretty
common for me I'm like
hooking up with other young people at
work
two workplaces like at the sushi place
were you throwing it down was it volcano
yeah I I had
I had sexual encounter with a co-worker
at volcano did she eat your butt at
volcano no I wasn't into that yet okay
the same shift as you
see
but I didn't know she was with somebody
at the time so her boyfriend called me
and he was so sad and he was crying and
then so I thought he was calling me to
fight and then I was like did he call
you and you're like volcano this is Joe
and then he's like hey well at first I
was like he'd be like thinking like what
was the point of the call he was just
saying like we were she promised me that
we were supposed to like uh like talk it
out so we were like really on a break
and then she was in the background
crying and stuff and I'm like thinking
why am I involved yeah but then I felt
bad for the guy so I was just like being
his like and then like yeah I'm like
yeah I'm sure she likes you and then I
think he was like do you like her like
he wanted Assurance from me Jesus and
then I'm like I like having sex with her
though yeah on upper guts that's sick
I'm sure she likes you but she cheated
on you with me yeah at that point I got
I I was I was like this girl's like
[__] trouble so it it may not yeah it
made me but it made me just want to stay
away because of how dangerous her
actions were like little damage because
what if this guy was violent and mean he
he probably it could have turned a
different way but it's I like violent
and mean
I'm so [__] mean
[Laughter]
I do like that he asked you if you like
her that's pretty weird honestly yes I
thought he was calling me to like
confront me and be all the I'll [__] you
up this and that and then I saw him do
he was like uh he was like a handsome
jock and [__] and whatever oh so like
but when I talked to him on the phone he
was like sad and and he and and he was
just being a human being about it so I
was just like I don't know what to say I
felt bad for him I didn't even know like
I didn't even know like she was in a
relationship but anyways after all that
I was like oh this is were you doing
YouTube at that time no I was just
working there interesting and you had
just found that you're like getting your
buddy and it was that not true no that's
not how long how many years afterwards a
couple of years I took a couple years
later okay it's not too far away maybe a
year or two close God we're close yeah
the other one was
um when I was working in shipping and
then you know so I was a warehouse dude
and she was in the sales office so she
was in the corporate side and you were
[__] on her pretty good we got we
started flirting
and I well she was much older than me so
I didn't think that it would be how much
older Dad yeah she's a grandma Yeah lady
no no I didn't get the booty he didn't
know
she already had she had she she had a
kid at an early age
so she was a mom but she she looked
really young but I think she was late
20s or early 30s and at this time I was
like 23 24. oh okay yeah so she used all
like when you're 24 someone who's 28 is
old he's [__] geriatric woman
I was 23 and I was [__] a 30 year old
and it feels like wow I'm like it's
crazy this woman wants me yeah it's
different it's pretty sweet honestly
yeah and I got her through improv of
course because I was funny like funny
guys and I like butts yeah oh yeah baby
but I do feel like
before dating apps right date before
dating apps and like what like how do
you mean people to just hook up with or
what it's got to be at the workplace
yeah and then I didn't go clubbing and
[__] yeah so I think like that makes
sense and then if you're attracted to
someone and you're always with them like
24 7 and you're single like and you have
reports you're gonna [__] them at work
you know what's funny notice that a lot
of my buddies who uh don't use dating
apps they [__] a lot at work
they [__] their their co-workers a lot
yeah I think that's dumb and every time
I'm like you ever go on the apps like no
dude I [__] hate the apps I'll never
go on the apps but they're [__] hours
yeah I like [__] with my money number
back in the day maybe this rumor didn't
reach where you were but there was a
really big uh rumor going around to not
sleep with girls from Nogales high no
because they had like a big herpes
outbreak oh wow I didn't know that wow
and then I always thought it was uh I
always thought it was like one of those
like oh let's talk [__] on the Rival
school yeah I thought it was just like a
rival rumor but then it turned out it
was actually true you know what they're
uh you know what their mascot was
The Dons it was like a it was a mafioso
guy did you know that oh really I didn't
know that I remember when we went to go
play them and I was like what the [__]
is their mascot it was like it's like
it's like a it's an outline a silhouette
of a of like a gangster guy did he have
like a big ass Ward on his dick yeah
yeah and it was like stop the spread of
HPV okay stops with you yeah yeah like
oh okay cool I I thought that this would
be kind of normal where like you got a
bunch of young people together
at the workplace there it would be weird
for them not to be hooking yeah not to
be [__] at McDonald's it's like it's
like the Olympic what is it for the
Olympics where they stay oh I heard
it to be there I heard it's total meat
party yeah
they have to like divvy out condoms like
every day who do you think the top um
Sports were busting it down are like
Batman
swimmers you think swimmers oh hell no
dude curling think about all the cows
that swimmers have to burn a day you
know they're [__] uh true pizza's in
between you know eating a whole Pizza
Hut pizza so keep the calories up and
[__] probably the power Walkers pole
vaulting pole vaulting oh yeah there's
some holes and she was like hell yeah
when they go in the air and then their
booty just [__] Twirls and you're
just like I love pole vaulting my
algorithm only shows me the men's
division
homosexual
it won't let me log in unless I admit it
so I have to hit yes so did you yeah my
face ID doesn't work let me go
Joe have you you [__] in this office
obviously no I haven't you've never
[__] into something no Bart have you
[__] in this office
I think so yeah where I don't remember I
don't remember where that's so dirty
you've never [__] in this office no
you've never [__] in this office
I did
multiple ways
you gotta take it against
it he jacked off with Hannah right nope
no another one
another one that's good okay DJ did you
did you she she asked me to FaceTime
Jack because it was a it was a long
distance
so I complied with her request
and I didn't have anything to finish on
so I finished on my table did you went
over there was there any part of it
[Laughter]
when you're on your phone and you're
doing long-distance relationship stuff
this is obviously the point where you
enjoy getting your buddy
do you put your butt against the phone
oh I can feel a little bit I can feel
something
are you like are you like stick your
tongue out and then you [__] yourself
I think you make you you make it ask him
ask him Steve hey have you [__] in
here or not no what yeah
we have evidence are you sure you better
be telling the camera we're about to
lose your [__] job if you lie why are
you eating a [__] house amateur tell
the truth what am I telling you if you
[__] in this office before or any of
the JK offices I have never never have I
ever [__] in the JK you sound like
you're lying and you take two smaller
bites out of the egg
take a bigger bite do you even have salt
on that egg yeah no Nick had this
question earlier have you ever been
[__] in this office whoa I didn't say
that whoa
I have been [__] by Nick in this
office you're gonna swear that dude okay
but did you like it that's the real
question yeah can I throw it down yeah
job I'm just kidding that's not hey fans
are talking about the sexual tension
between us have you ever been close to
to [__] in this office you ever never
ever ever not even ever you never get a
handy or nothing in here bro what by who
there's been times where this fool was
like hey guys this is my friend we're
gonna go back here remember in the
middle of filming yeah yeah dude I
always assumed anyone that had a key
here probably ended up [__] here at
one point at one point I just assumed
yeah right on those couches it's way too
dark
too close right here it doesn't it
doesn't turn me on when I walk into the
JK office man wow now you tell us you
guys want to hear a rumor that I heard
yeah I heard Anthony [__] the couch
couch couch yeah I heard you that's my
couch I know I heard you put the
cushions together and he started
whispering at it and I already started
whispering
all right
foreign